-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Timothy Olyphant.
I'm so excited about this.
You know I've said this
in the past,
I'm a huge fan of the show
"Justified,"
which had a wonderful run.
And now you've just
finished shooting
a new limited series,
8 new episodes of the show.
-Yeah.
-Raylan Givens is back.
-But even more exciting,
your daughter,
your youngest daughter,
has been cast in the show.
-Can I just say the first thing
that went through my mind?
"Is it more exciting?"
[ Laughter ]
I mean...
I'm happy for her,
don't get me wrong,
but why is --
I'm still, underneath
this bull[bleep] exterior,
just a neurotic actor.
-Yeah, yeah. I'm sorry.
-And all I heard there was,
somehow my kid coming back
was more exciting...
-Let me rephrase that.
Just a fraction as exciting
as you being back.
It's barely news that
your daughter is in it.
-My daughter is playing
my daughter
in the "Justified" revival.
-That's exciting, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-She's still a teenager, right?
-She's a teenager.
-So what's it like having
a teenage daughter on set?
-I don't recommend it.
[ Laughter ]
You know, here's the downside.
She, uh...
Here's one of the things about
"Justified" in particular
is that over time, you've earned
a little bit of reputation
where perhaps people,
and just how you are,
the number on the call sheet,
people can be a little bit
nervous around you
or feel intimidated,
and they're just very
careful around you.
We hired the one person,
guaranteed,
doesn't feel that way at all.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, she's not only
not nervous around me,
she's kind of over it.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
So it's such a strange thing to
be working with your daughter,
and you're, like, gonna
give a note or a suggestion...
-'Cause it should be known,
you're also an EP on the show.
You're a producer on the show.
-That's what I kept
reminding her.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause she's like,
"Dad, no. Stop it.
[ Laughter ]
Ugh!
God!
Just leave me alone."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "I'm the star
of the [bleep]...
You can't..."
Do you know what it's like
to have to whisper
to your daughter,
like, "You can't
talk to me like that."
[ Laughter ]
On the set of your own show?
It's terrible.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Nobody
talks to me like that.
This is like..." Yeah.
It was really quite lovely.
-It's a bummer that she's also
playing your daughter,
which she does in real life.
I know you're not
the same person,
but she must feel like she knows
exactly how to do it.
-Seth, that's me.
-Yeah, that's you?
You're Raylan Givens? You are?
-Pretty much.
-Well, to quote Snoop Dogg...
[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm trying
to get across.
-Which you've begged us to do.
-It was an incredible
experience.
I have to say,
she was remarkable,
and it was a joy to
work with her.
She worked very hard.
She auditioned for it,
and I wasn't surprised
that they hired her.
It was really special.
-That's very cool.
I did hear she did
some on-set polling.
What was the polling
she was doing?
-Oh, she did all that
bull[bleep]
where she would put, like --
she'd write, like,
"Favorite Olyphant"
on a big board
and put my name and her name.
[ Laughter ]
Look -- the crew's laughing!
I lost in a landslide.
[ Laughter ]
Like, a landslide.
It was like,
one "Star Wars" geek
that voted for me.
He's like, "Oh, I saw him
in 'The Mandalorian.'"
He was the only guy
who gave me a vote.
It was terrible.
-Yeah.
-No, she was terrible.
-Oh, I'm very sorry.
I'm very sorry that your life
continues to be so rough.
[ Laughter ]
I really, I cannot wait
to see "Justified" coming back,
and I'm very excited
about "Amsterdam" as well.
-That's very kind of you.
I'm just thrilled to be here.
It's great to see you.
-It's always great to see you.
-I'm in town, by the way.
-I know, you're here
for three months.
-So we can...
-If anybody drops out,
you'll be here, right?
-That's what I'm saying.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, no.
It's coming across
loud and clear.
You guys,
that's Timothy Olyphant!
-Thank you.
-"Amsterdam" is in theaters
Friday, October 7th.